who is first okay go ahead first of all
this one because of determination there
is as you know 12 criterias to fulfill
in order to qualify for the capital for
the green capital of Europe
and Lisbon started its way beginning of
2010 2011 so it's been a long way huge
work has been done but most importantly
it's also determinations and plans for
the future and Lisbon showed very
clearly that they were willing to do it
right now right here and also move fast
for the future this is why Lisbon and
what will be being back to be in this no
in this challenge of climate change I
think most importantly is a clean air
clean water and this is the major
commitments Lisbon has made moving
forward but also let's not forget it
gives a additional exposure for Lisbon
as a city to attract additional tourists
and again for citizens for people of
Lisbon to live and enjoy clean parks
spend time with the family near to a
clean water and and of course in the
fresh clean air and mayor said very
clearly you know you have a river a few
years ago it was dangerous to to swim
now it's with the improving sewage
system in a couple years you will have a
possibility to dive in I think it's a
it's a great ambition to move forward
but of course much more has to be done
especially speaking about the mobility
mobility has to be the one solving
citizens problems to connect from A to B
but also it has to be zero
and this one has made a great move with
electric buses gas powered vs. is a
temporary solution of course and by 2050
it can be definitely exchanged for a
zero pollution we saw lots of young
people here today in the Pacific all
young people already did a terrific job
they were the ones reminding politicians
that politicians has to act they were
the ones putting a green deal top of the
agenda for the European Commission I
think they have to keep being mobilized
they have to keep being vocal and
reminding politicians not only in you
level but also regional and national
level what are their commitments what
they promised to do and to make sure
that those promises deliver and of
course everyone can start from
themselves
looking at their carbon footprint how
then they can change their every day
behavior and I think young people can be
role model for all of us thank you
next one shoot I think without cities we
can't achieve anything because if you
look at across Europe whereas the
innovation taking place in cities where
are people with the most talent going to
that's in cities where are the biggest
problems also in cities and where are
the biggest solutions also cities so the
city is sort of the the nexus where
everything comes together but that's not
the whole story because the cities will
also have to take the responsibility for
the development of rural areas so what I
always save the cities yes it's good
that you take the lead but look at your
surroundings who is feeding you where do
the people live who come to work in your
cities and how do people you know enjoy
themselves outside of the city where did
they go to to rural areas so we also
need to create a partnership between
cities and rural areas
we're European Union faces the challenge
like the like brexit do you think that
that mean deal can be an opportunity for
countries to gather around a common
objective with common interests well I
honestly believe that the Green Deal is
Europe's destiny and I also believe that
in the last year's many people in Europe
citizens have been sort of struggling
what is what is Europe for what is our
destiny and I have the feeling broadly
in European society the idea that we
need to transform a society to make it
sustainable is supported by many people
and most people know that they can't do
this individually in Member States that
they need the European Union for this so
I believe the Green Deal is really the
new sort of destiny for the European
Union and I also believe that most
European citizens understand this is
something we really need to do today we
heard several calls for the biggest
polluters to act and also in Europe we
have big polluters like Poland that
didn't sign or didn't go on board of the
Green Deal yet and do you think that
that can be a problem or not but we
should also be honest about the fact
that not everybody is in the same
position Portugal has made incredible
investments over the last years and now
renewable energy accounts for more than
50 percent of Portuguese energy makes in
Poland 80 percent of the energy is still
based on coal so their need for
transformation is much more profound and
much more expensive than other member
states so when the Polish government
asked for some solidarity I have some
understanding for this but Poland
doesn't do this just because of the rest
of the world or just because of the rest
of Europe they do this because their own
citizens are demanding this because the
air quality in Polish cities is really
was really bad can I ask a question so
like you just said they are various
speeds over the course of European and
these implementations can we achieve our
global goals with these various speeds
in the way
well I'd the only thing I can tell you
for sure because we did the preparation
for this is that Europe can be climate
neutral by 2050 that we can do and I
have the impression also in the
conference in Madrid that if we make
these plans concrete and we start doing
this we will convince more and more
parts of the world to do the same thing
to move in the same direction so the
only thing we can do to make it happen
is to start now and to understand that
we can do this we have the technology we
have the capital we have the willingness
to do it so let's get going
fundamental absolutely fundamental you
know I don't think everywhere in Europe
Lisbon is on the map as a green city but
now that Lisbon has a start of European
Green Capital we will see that other
cities will you know be curious why is
that what are they doing there what is
happening with sustainable housing hey
interesting they're moving to electric
mobility how are they doing that so I
think it's it's very important to
convince others about what we're talking
about that not not every countries in
the same starting point the just
transition fund will be fundamental for
this is there already a budget which
countries will be in will be out when
can we see more news about the judge to
newsroom from on Tuesday Tuesday we will
take a decision on this in the College
of Commissioners and I hope to be able
to present the result in Strasbourg on
Tuesday
thank you yes go ahead
well I think there is a broad
willingness in the three institutions to
counsel the European Parliament and the
Commission to have a good and long look
at what does Europe need which
instruments do we need what are the
urgencies of our citizens the only
message I would have you know also with
my experience campaigning in Europe for
the European elections is this let's
talk about the people's problems not our
problems people are not interested in
our problems they are interested in what
we can do to help solve their problems
and I hope the conference will
concentrate on that thank you very much